transition before we go into the news I
want to tell you guys my Thanos sketch
idea because I'm never gonna make it
like three separate segments of Dan was
running a restaurant
hmm and like he can't afford the
employees just wipes out having a voice
why don't you despite there are too many
people in the dining room too many
people waiting in line this snaps yeah
half the seats are open there's half the
one everybody's happy
then it goes to one word Venice is
coaching a kids soccer team but they
keep losing fun isn't something one
considers when coaching happens with
kids and then the mom comes freaking out
and she's like why'd you kill my son I'm
just like don't worry you can start
fresh I wiped out half the parents to
the people you hate on this field or
girl and then the third one he's running
like a store like a Sephora oh and
people walk in and it's it's too
expensive
I'm gonna cut could see like an
infomercial of Thanos in a suit going
are you looking to buy a car today but
can't afford one well you can't get a
lease for a thousand a month let's cut
this in half Santos the mad Titan of
slashing prices left they said I was mad
well I'm mad about how expensive these
VCRs are yeah
my girlfriend actually came up with that
last part and she got the from this one
happy Friday reject nation it's Greg
the man did judge a man we got more
infinity Wars taught to do right that's
that's all the news that matters that's
all the movie news that matters why talk
about Bill and Ted three or Tenacious
D's Pick of Destiny two we don't need
two we're only gonna talk about infinity
war when it comes to movie news from now
on even when Avengers 4 comes out it's
gonna be all about video before we do
that patron of the day shoutout to JT
the man from Hawaii JT we usually do a
Google hangout with you once a month
buddy but we didn't hang out with you
last month I'm flabbergasted I am pissed
I am worried I'm concerned yeah it's a
wide variety of emotions I feel like I'm
going through a breakup right now
because you're the only one on patreon
that we haven't talked to you about
infinity for we need to hear your
opinion we need to know your thoughts
and feelings on the matter did Santos
wipe you out is that what happened dude
what a Santos wipe JT out although I
mean I guess he missed out on the
volcano so that's what yeah on to some
movie news sure you guys are like man
take a long time to get there right so
we got three things to talk about here
that wasn't in there the first thing I
want to talk about it is the big one
grew its final line in infinity war if
you guys haven't seen infinity war route
is the only one who dies I actually
watch this a third time the third time I
watched this was my favorite time I
think it was because there's none of
that crazy energy in the theatre which
can aid in a movie gonna go and
experience but for a film like this I'm
aware I have to shoot a movie right
after I shoulda sighs anything I got a
really bad my he knows his third time I
saw our IMAX 2d and it was just a really
relaxing experiences there's barely
anyone in the theater I was able to
absorb the film it was the first time I
watched it cuz before I would say I
loved a lot of it this was the first
time watching I said I just loved this
whole movie a lot of the criticism I
even had I actually would take back and
now that I'm able to just sit back in
his orbit in a natural way one moment
that really got me was groots left final
line because I had heard what his final
line is when I watched it the first
couple of times I was like
it's a bummer he'll be back though you
know knowing that groots final line is
dad that he says to rocket man that got
me teary-eyed when I watch it that time
knowing what he's actually saying
emotionally really gets me and it aids
even more in groots whole arc in that
movie Groot is you know he's just on his
game the whole time he doesn't really
care about anything that's going on
everyone smile he picks his head up to
take a little bit of interest decides to
help out Thor starts fighting in the
battle you see that he has a connection
he's like the son of former Groot right
like he's the biological son or
something like that he doesn't have any
of the memories or whatever but he's
like biologically based on greed so it
had me going like maybe he's a guy who
wishes he knew his actual real
biological dad and but he sees rocket as
his father now and he's you know that
that moment is his party it's a
father-and-son moment and that moment
really got me teary-eyed and I wish
there was a one time I wish there was a
subtitle yeah because you know there are
people who learn elvish I'm sure
somebody will crack the group let's go
on to the next one here this one I think
is very intriguing Joe and Anthony Russo
we're talking about how there's so many
things in the trailers that are not in
the actual films it's weird this is the
one time I think for a movie that had
trailer footage cut up differently or
shots that are just flat-out not in the
movie not upset anyone
other than the main shot that one where
they're all running and it's kind of
like choreographed yeah yeah other than
the main shot people wanting that one
moment everything else no one seemed
upset about I find it interesting how
one of the biggest quotes of this movie
is not in the actual film this is
something one considers for balance
[Music]
I've heard people complain about this
phenomenon before there are a lot of
movies were like oh that's scene you
know got me amped up for that it didn't
even happen I feel like this movie has
the right combination of nobody who
really wants to know what actually
happens in infinity more they just want
to know what infinity wars gonna feel
like and kind of hint at me yeah they
have found this weird place where I
guess it's just sort of okay with people
that they didn't give us Oh totally and
then now here's where Joe Russo had to
say we use all the material that we have
at our disposal to create a trailer we
look at the trailer and a very different
experience in the movie and I think
audiences are so predictive now they get
to be very smart about how you craft a
trailer because an audience can watch
the trailer and basically tell you
what's gonna happen the film that's what
we do trailers revisit we consume too
much content so at our disposal are lots
of different shots that aren't in the
movie that we can manipulate through CG
to tell a story they want to tell
specifically for the purpose of the
trailer not for the film I think that's
smart because there's there's a couple
of things I noticed like when Spiderman
zipping around that the closer to the
second official trailer they have that
shot in the movie except he has the legs
out and he's throwing a mantis around
yeah yeah yeah and then he got asked
about the shot the hero shot the shot
that you're referencing was never in the
movie version that you saw it was never
created for the movie in that version it
was literally created in that version
for the trailer in a way it's kind of a
moving poster and I guess you know you
wind up with so much footage they said
like we can manipulate all this stuff
with CGI and I guess I don't like I
understand the complaint that like it's
false advertising but at the same time
I'm like you do have so much footage
that is of and related to your movie and
yeah if you can manipulate that in a way
that gets the point across especially in
that like you said it's like a poster
it's just an image it's not contextual
that because technically that scene of
them all fighting that except for Hulk
the scene of the hmmm fighting is all in
the movie so if it's all in the movie
like there's really matter they don't
get that one cool shot and it wouldn't
have fit to and I think that's the thing
that people are not really complaining
about would this film is there going
well that wouldn't have fit they
acknowledge this line fun isn't
something
one considers when balance in the
universe but this does put a smile on my
face but they said was that was the
scripted line for the movie that were
replaced with another line that we
thought was a little more specific to
the storytelling of Gamora
I think he used to say that on nowhere -
Gamora when he emerged on the reality
cloak as the Ethan her exposed him and I
think we changed it as something that
was a little more specific to the
storytelling I put out a tweet saying
fun isn't something one considers open
line said the trailer or not in the
actual movie a lot of people reply back
well where would this line I've gone and
that's true because it wouldn't have
worked for Thanos the the actions of
interpretation fun yeah and it just it
wouldn't have been fitting for his
character in that scene or a later scene
yeah and that was one thing that was
abundantly clear to me like I'd see how
you could argue about the hero shot but
that line especially having seen the
movie at least twice I was like yeah I
can't figure out where that would have
gone this again would have been in a
different movie version of them yeah and
then the last thing to talk about which
I find intriguing and kind of [ __ ]
perfectly Tom the whole an improvised
Scarlet Witch is actually all him on the
ADR so they were talking about why
scarlet witch's accent was not really
there here's what I want to say before
we go into this I have never thought
Elizabeth Olsen did a good Russian
accent never no it's always sounded
pretty bad to me I've always thought her
performance is good but was not as
performance is fine but the voice is not
good so I can emot-- through that accent
oh yeah yeah oh she's a good like the
emotional stuff is all there it's just
the accent itself is not the greatest
but here's what they said in regards to
it we haven't actually tried to strip
that accent away for a couple reasons
one is you'll notice at the beginning of
Civil War that Black Widow is training
her to be a spy and two is she's been on
the run and one of the most
distinguishing characteristics that she
has is her accent so if you're gonna try
to disguise yourself or hide yourself or
not be caught you're going to try to
limit those trigger warnings so make it
easy for someone to identify you
which would be inclusive of her accent
literally black widow as a redhead is an
incredibly distinguishing characteristic
for her which is why she has blonde hair
cap we've seen Chris Evans walk around
in public with a beard or known
recognize him there are simple things
you can do to your parents to take about
90 percent of your visibility away and
for us it was very intentional who just
keeps tripping that accent down to show
her acclimating and hiding well I don't
think it's come
bs I feel like it was a justification to
get her on it's like yeah they went this
isn't going well a lot of people were
pointing it out we got to do this it's
kind of like Halle Berry in the x-men
trilogy the for the original three-part
one she's like she she's trying an
accent part three I'm like she has no
accident to me this is a one of those
things is not like the others where I'm
like the other two examples are physical
changes around likes girl which still
looks exactly like which it's just if
she opens her mouth somebody near Maya
might not go what is that you know so
craziness over there oh yeah it's a big
thing I just feel like this you kind of
should have been acknowledged in some
capacity in either Civil War or infinity
ward this is an intentional thing
because this just leaves a lot of
viewers going what's happier voice I I
mean why she's trying even less now do
you think I've ever had that experience
during a movie that I did during
infinity war where I was like I'm
distracted by the fact that this is
different however I don't mind I think
that's actually probably a better idea
yeah I say this relaxed it's really not
a big deal you know this infinity war
stuff has been a lot of fun over on
patreon we're answering a lot of Q&A
thoughts about you know what we think is
gonna happen with Avengers 4 it's cool
it's cool it's like the first time
there's a Marvin let's come up we're all
talking about what's coming next and
it's exciting it's really exciting stuff
it's not that device well guys thanks
for tuning in you guys can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification Belko subscribe buttons
don't really do the job check us on
patreon full-length TV show reactions
music video reactions as those usually
get blocked on here like the last few
done and also weekly q and A's so love
to have you become a patreon objected
day